648 the sunrise Sun trying to Peak up
over the Eastern Horizon which you can
see all those clouds it's an overcast
morning and we are at 38 degrees which
is six degrees warmer than we were at
this time yesterday you can thank the
insulation provided by that cloud cover
that's also kept the humidity up dew
point at 17 degrees of South Southwest
winds at five it's not going to get much
stronger than that temperatures around
the valley in the mid 30s the only
freezing point I could find was up at
Nellis and that is usually one of the
cooler thermometers up in that and that
Sunrise Manor too up in that northeast
corner of the valley
25-32 in Pahrump 41 down in the Colorado
River Valley Laughlin high pressure
holding off this mess up here and we'll
be ridging over us into Christmas and
we're not going to get any of the cold
Arctic air that's coming east of the
Rockies it's going to be stormy too in
the the Northeast we're looking at a
snowstorm uh probably a white Christmas
for them but not for us we've got a
white in our skies this morning they
will that those clouds will burn off and
then a lot of sunshine this afternoon 37
for the overnight low tonight so not as
cold as previous mornings and our most
accurate eight day forecast oh boy this
is a winner remember this is a December
first day of winter tomorrow and we're
talking about 60 to 65 over Christmas
holiday